hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for
anime uproar and in this video i will be
addressing everyone's biggest fear about
the latest and absolutely crazy twist in
the one piece story as we know from back
in chapter 1043
monkey d luffy died in his fight against
kaido and he was then reborn as the
legendary joy boy the mythical
historical figure from the void century
who was prophesized to one day return
and usher in a new dawn but what happens
if this newly reborn luffy isn't the
same monkey luffy that we've grown to
love over these 1000 plus chapters what
if the return of joy boy and luffy's
devil fruit awakening are more than just
a cool power up what if they change
luffy forever and not necessarily for
the better that is what i will be
talking about in this video so let's get
into it you guys know the drill if you
enjoy our one piece content and you want
to see more in the future just leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it really helps with that
youtube algorithm and remember that
subscribing and hitting that bell is a
completely free way of directly
supporting the channel and it actually
helps us out a lot finally this video
will contain one piece manga spoilers
including chapter
1044 spoilers
this is at the end of the day a
speculative video but i still have to
use all the information that we have
available so far so please proceed with
caution you have been warned now we've
all been hyped about this massive new
luffy transformation and it goes without
saying that in some ways luffy has just
changed forever he is going to be
stronger than ever before and that is
certainly going to be amazing to see but
we have to consider the possibility that
this new stronger luffy this resurrected
luffy was brought about the return of
joy boy may no longer be the same luffy
we know the most recent events in the
story have revealed that luffy's devil
fruit the gomu gomu no me is not what it
appeared to be the gomu gomu no me is
actually a mythical zone devil fruit
called the hitohito nomi or human human
fruit mythical model nica not only that
but the gorosei are aware of this
legendary fruit they considered to be
extremely dangerous a direct threat to
their power and they have been trying to
get their hands on it for a very long
time they almost succeeded in capturing
it but then shanks took it luffy ate it
and all of their plans fell through in
fact it is said that zone devil fruits
have a mind of their own and it is as if
the legendary nika devil fruit has been
consciously running away from the
gorosei this is of course a massive
revelation because the one piece fandom
has been speculating for a very long
time that devil fruits may be alive each
devil fruit may have its own will maybe
even its own consciousness and this will
and consciousness may belong to a
previous user or users of that specific
devil fruit
after all if the devil fruits themselves
can be reincarnated after their user
dies who's to say that some part of the
user like their will or consciousness
cannot also be reincarnated along with
the fruit something like this has been
hinted at for a very long time after
sabo consumes ace's former devil fruit
the mera meranomi it is implied that he
inherited more than just aces power
there seems to be something of aces
still within the fruit and sabo has
inherited that as well we don't know
what exactly this something is is it
ace's spiritual presence ace's will
ace's personality and so on but there
does seem to be something there then we
have the example of an animated object
such as a gun or a sword eating devil
fruits now obviously when a human or
other sentient creature eats a devil
fruit they will continue to function as
sentient beings with their own
personality because that's how they were
before eating the fruit but since most
inanimate objects don't have a
personality a will or in essence certain
special swords accepted then the fact
that these inanimate object devil fruits
are able to function as sentient living
beings means that the ability to
function as a sentient being comes from
the devil fruits themselves there is
some sort of sentience some sort of will
or presence within devil fruits that
allows even inanimate objects to become
sentient upon consuming a devil fruit to
be fair all known examples of inanimate
objects consuming devil fruits come from
zone devil fruits but now that we know
that luffy's devil fruit is actually a
mythical zone the argument still stands
devil fruits and especially zone devil
fruits have a will or presence of their
own and while this presence may be
dormant most of the time that is clearly
no longer the case for luffy with the
awakening of his devil fruit something
else has awoken inside of him a separate
essence that zunesha straight up refers
to as joy boy himself so what is this
essence exactly and how will it affect
luffy one possible scenario is a very
controversial one and that is the
possibility that luffy himself is the
literal reincarnation of joy boy a
historical figure who lived during the
void century this means that joy boy
isn't necessarily inside the devil fruit
he is actually inside of luffy but the
devil fruit somehow triggered his
awakening perhaps this nika devil fruit
with a will of its own has been
searching for the reincarnation of its
former user joyboy and it eventually
found that reincarnation
in monkey d luffy now this possibility
has been widely criticized by many
members of the community because they
believe that reincarnation is just a
cheap literary trope and it constitutes
bad writing if luffy is a reincarnation
then he won't be his own unique person
with his own unique will and destiny and
that cheapens his entire character arc
while i don't necessarily want luffy to
be a literal reincarnation of joy boy i
have to say that people criticizing this
possibility don't seem to have a proper
understanding of how reincarnation works
especially in buddhism and of course
buddhism has been a huge influence on
oda and it has been referenced many
times in the story i don't want to get
too deep into buddhist beliefs in this
video but it is important to stress that
for people who believe in reincarnation
like buddhists hindus and others
reincarnation is not just a cheap trope
it is a widely accepted reality
something it just is and something that
goes without saying just as you might
accept that all people who live will
eventually die someone who believes in
reincarnation accepts that all people
who one day die will also be
reincarnated there is a lot more there
including the concepts of karma samsara
nirvana and so on but the important
point is this the way that reincarnation
is understood in japan is not the way
that it is understood in the west it is
not just a lazy literary trope it is far
deeper far more complex and far more
culturally and spiritually rooted okay
now having said that what happens if
luffy really is a reincarnation of joy
boy and his awakening suddenly triggers
his memories of that previous life
presumably luffy would suddenly become
aware of everything that the original
joyboy was aware of all of his life
experiences would suddenly also become
luffy's life experiences not only would
this potentially change luffy as a
person but it would also fundamentally
change the story for the worse i mean
think about it if luffy remembered his
previous life as joy boy he would
suddenly gain knowledge about the void
century he would suddenly know
everything about laughtale in one piece
and all the mysteries of the world would
be solved in an instant in the past
luffy outright refused to be told the
secrets of the world because he wanted
to unlock those secrets himself during
his journey to become the pirate king
and this is why i don't think that luffy
will turn out to be the literal
reincarnation of joy boy it's not that
the concept of reincarnation itself is
bad writing it's just that in this case
it would go against so much that oda has
already established over the course of
the story it would be one thing if luffy
was the reincarnation of joyboy but this
knowledge remained dormant at least
until the end of the story but now that
joyboy has awakened right here in moano
it just doesn't make sense for luffy to
become one with joyboy at this time i
mean luffy would literally become a
walking spoiler for the ending of one
piece
but if it's not luffy himself who is joy
boy then joyboy's awakening is likely
directly related to the gomugo munomi or
rather the nikanika nomi in this
scenario joyboy has returned because
some part of him his will or his essence
or something had been sealed away inside
the devil fruit that we know as the gomu
gomu no me but joy boy could not be
reborn until the fruit was fully
awakened and because it hadn't awakened
in 800 years joy boy had not been seen
since the void century however now that
joyboy has awakened what does this mean
exactly if his will or essence was
inside the fruit and so it's not one and
the same with luffy's essence that means
that our luffy will remain the same
person but it also means that there will
be an internal conflict between luffy
and joy boy within luffy's body now this
is a trope that has been used in just
about any long-running shonen i can
think of and it can result in some
really interesting character drama as
our hero struggles to come to terms with
a secondary personality inside of him
this internal conflict could result in
joyboy outright possessing luffy's body
or in luffy losing control of his powers
and going berserk in that sense rather
than luffy eating the devil fruit the
devil fruit could actually be eating him
as it overtakes his personality and
consumes him from the inside
that would make for an interesting
character arc as luffy struggles to
regain control of his body and his
powers and honestly it would kind of
make sense for something like this to
happen from everything we know so far
luffy's new powers are absolutely
incredible and if there is not some sort
of serious drawback to using them they
will be absolutely broken i mean luffy
could theoretically just breeze through
the rest of the story on easy mode and
absolutely wreck every obstacle that
stands in his way with his new godly
power but if using this power comes at
the price of temporarily being possessed
by another entity and or losing control
of yourself and going berserk then luffy
will have to struggle long and hard in
order to fully master his new power and
that means that he won't be able to just
speedrun elbaf and laughtale he still
has a long way to go and the villains
including blackbeard the admirals and
emu still have a chance of defeating him
i mean as much as any villain has a
chance of defeating a shonen protagonist
so i predict that using his new godly
powers will come at a great cost to
luffy this cost may come in the form of
losing control and going berserk or
maybe even being outright possessed by
joyboy whose will or essence has been
residing within the devil fruit formerly
known as the gomu gomu nomi so luffy
will need to work harder than ever
before to master this new power without
losing control and he will have to come
to terms with an alien will living
inside of him the will of joy boy and
speaking of wills i feel like a lot of
people talk about inherited will in one
piece but they never bother actually
explaining what this means often when
they talk about it it feels like they're
just talking about an idea like the idea
of freedom so it's like joy boy believed
in freedom and now luffy believes in
freedom so when they say that luffy
inherited joy boy's will it's almost
like he inherited his ideology but
clearly there is more going on here than
just a shared ideology or shared ideas
chapter 143 proves this zunesha did not
say that luffy has the same ideas about
freedom as joy boy no zunesha said that
joy has literally returned so there is
more going on here than just sharing the
same great ideas about freedom all in
all regardless of what kind of internal
conflict he faces luffy will eventually
succeed because he is our protagonist
and because we love him as a character
and we love all the development that he
has gone through i am sure that the
negative changes that occur as a result
of this new transformation will be
temporary knowing what we know so far
it's hard to imagine a scenario where
some sort of internal conflict doesn't
take place without a conflict of this
kind luffy just becomes overpowered to
the point that his strength is on par
with a god without any serious drawbacks
and it is still too early in the story
for something like that to happen and
yes i know saying it's too early when
we're over a thousand chapters into the
story seems pretty silly but when you
look at the narrative structure of one
piece we still have a long way to go
before everything is wrapped up and the
story ends there are still so many
mysteries to resolve and so many
adventures to be had there is still
elbaf and laugh tale and the world
government and blackbeard and shanks and
vegapunk and the ancient weapons and so
on so i believe that luffy's greatest
weapon his devil fruit may also become
his greatest challenge in the coming
chapters as he struggles to control and
come to terms with his new power he will
have to resist potential possession from
joy boy through the devil fruit and he
will have to ensure that the insane
power of sun god nika doesn't overwhelm
him and consume him from the inside
luffy will almost certainly triumph in
the end but as is always the case with
one piece it's all about the journey not
the destination if you guys enjoyed this
video and you want to see more one piece
content here on the channel leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it really helps with that
youtube algorithm and remember that
subscribing and hitting that bell is a
completely free but very important way
of directly supporting the channel you
can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror i want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible special thank you to kyle
salisbury this man is an absolute mad
lad and a disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including alpha sigma in
grata algital pate heffa the red-haired
fox hinokami and water the toasted qi
corey mcgowan spider-left tennelle
tungsten tarkis big buddhist and jeremy
cummings finally thank you also to our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel cruz
alicia ochter bonnie parks joe and
garcia fat boy games kaido might be a
duck jessica rabbit jeremy phillips and
alivania if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you